monsieur landes ski
avez vous entendu parler du crime
organisé
je n'ai aucune information à ce sujet
monsieur lens qui c'est un plaisir
pourquoi vous voulez écrire un livre à
propos de moi peut-être bien que j'aime
les histoires sur les personnes
compliqué tout ce que je déciderai de te
dire restera entre nous jusqu'à ce que
je t'autorise à l'écrire dans ton
bouquin toutes les conversations que tu
auras à mon propos je veux que tu me les
10 et si tu me trouves
tu as subira les conséquences
je n'ai pas le pouvoir de changer mon
passé près seulement le pouvoir de
changer la perception qu mandat
j'ai monté mon business en partant de
rien
je ne choisis pas de côté
je choisis des opportunités fait en
sorte qu'ils en bavent non
on vous considérait toujours comme
faisant partie de la pègre nous n'étions
plus considéré comme tel nous étions
enfin conchie
en ski à cacher quelque part plus de 300
millions de dollars et nous voulons vous
nous aidiez à les retrouver nous
pourrions au lycée à monsieur l'antique
vous avez raconté ses petits secrets ça
risque de mal tourner pour vous
il y à des individus dans ce monde qui
essaieront toujours nous faire croire
qu'ils sont meilleurs que nous la rage
c'est l'outil dont on se sert pour leur
prouver qu'ils ont tort je ne doute pas
des décisions que je prends
on a tout sur listing l'argent blanchi
l'entrée sortait de genève
quand tu perds ta réputation tu as tout
perdu rappelle-toi se laisse jamais tes
émotions dicter ses actes
non
avec une sale gueule
c'est ce que vous vous dites pour
pouvoir dormir la nuit non je n'ai pas
besoin de me dire quoi que ce soit on a
les brochets
c'est comme ça qu'on vit c'est le
business